mais moi cette musique rire et vous
verrez quand je serai vieille vous
verrez vous serez tout comme moi
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'il ya je suis pas
grosse je suis dilatées oui dilatées
c'est normal quand on a eu 12 enfants
comme moi lui monsieur dose et je les ai
bien élevé et je les ai tous marée basse
comme là il reste ma fille fortier
fortunés fortune et qu'est-ce que tu
caches derrière ton dos bien ici qu'est
ce que tu cacher ton dos des talents
aiguilles
qu'est ce que tu fous avec des talons
aiguilles dans le dos c'est en bois
quelle boîte n'est pas les mots dire je
vais me préparer je vais t'accompagner
tu vas pas aller tout seul nom a envie
de chercher qui sait qu'il est de
chercher un type quelqu'un comment il
s'appelle qu'est ce qu'ils font les
parents à ça me regarde pas ah ben ça me
regarde pas mais écoute moi bien
fortunés moi je sais exactement comment
ça se passe avec les types de ce site le
site
il va venir te chercher il va t'amener à
la boîte et ben vous rêviez de chercher
votre main droite une fois en boîte
il va vouloir te payer un verre
et baettig oui tu bois un verre qu'est
ce qui est appris va vouloir invite à
danser a battu du oui tu vas tu t'en ce
qu'est ce qu'il ya tu peux t'éclate
kényan a pris à vouloir te ramener mais
il va pas se garer devant la maison il
va se garer 100 mètres plus loin
et alors là alors là il va vouloir et va
vouloir
et va vouloir embrasser sur la bouche et
ben t'es dur oui qu'est-ce qui a
embrassé sur la bouche non après il va
vouloir et va vouloir il va vouloir
toucher la poitrine
oui marine oui il va vouloir toucher la
poitrine et ben tu dis mais qu'est ce
qui a fait éclater aussi nord mais a pas
trop infortunés parce que les fruits
une sortie dont les a touchés plus
personne ne les achetez un après après
va vouloir
comment dire et va vouloir et va vouloir
te monte dessus mais ma fille c'est
comme ça il va vouloir te monte dessus
alors là tu dis non tu as compris tu dit
non parce que tu te montent dessus c'est
le déshonneur surtout khatami qui a
compris
qu'est ce qui a fait précise que la qia
35 ans 35 ans et ben alors tu dis oui je
dis oui mais attention fortunés c'est
toi qui lui montent dessus comme ça ça
sera le déshonneur sur sa famille à lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]